E aí
[Música]
a todos nós somos luzes que esperam
brilhar onde já brilharam e nunca
perceberam
todo mundo tem uma ideia para agregar no
dia a dia por mais que seja para si ou
seja para as pessoas só rezar
e sendo assim todo mundo pode fazer
ciência já já aqui na minha visão eu
tenho 14 anos conseguir criar um projeto
através de uma única frase
e o essencial é invisível aos olhos
aquela famosa frase do Pequeno Príncipe
que me inspirou a criar um projeto Então
hoje eu vim contar um pouco para vocês
sobre essa trajetória no ano passado
é bom todo mundo sabe que o ano passado
foi um ano conturbado e difícil e esse
ano ainda está sendo e claro não foi
diferente para mim
acontecendo coisas péssimas nessas
intenção de 2019 para dizem 20 eu perdi
pessoas queridas então não tava tão
pronta para uma Vinícius
é mais que uma vida não para e ela tem
continuar eu tive que voltar para as
minhas aulas em Fevereiro eu tinha
acabado de ingressar no 8º ano e junto
uma nova matéria foi em seguida o eixo
de interiores
Oi hoje literárias tem a ideia principal
que pegar todas as disciplinas todas as
matérias e colocar numa única destacando
as habilidades que o aluno tem e que ele
se desempenha melhor e assim a gente
pode levar temas para dentro da sala
temas polêmicos de bater eles e também a
gente pode levar para fora da sala com
pena os muros escolares
Ah e ainda naquele ano o tema principal
daquele eixo era o essencial é invisível
aos olhos a frase que eu tinha dito no
começo
a ideia principal do seu temática era
olhar para ser e não para ter porque nós
somos muito mais do que bem materiais
nós somos humanos
e a parte disso a gente conversou com
questionamento o que a gente vê e o que
a gente não veio como pessoas
é bom a partir disso a gente Partiu para
dois sentidos o primeiro ele foi outro
sentido real que a gente estudou sobre o
funcionamento dos olhos como nosso olhar
capítulos a imagem e leva para o cérebro
e o outro foi sentido figurado onde a
gente estudou como cada pessoa consegue
interpretar o mundo da sua forma
e a partir disso eu e minha sala
conseguimos concluir que cada pessoa tem
uma visão diferente sobre o mundo e uma
dessas pessoas são as pessoas com
deficiência visual
então a gente começou a fazer vários
conteúdos voltados a pessoa cega como
cão-guia é leis e direitos e o que me
chamou muita atenção que foi de um
remédio que é um pintor cego e ele pinta
através de pressão da música Eu super
Recomendo vocês pesquisarem uma hora e
veremos Quase dei as pinturas dele
porque são lindas Ah e ainda nessa mesma
época a minha professora Érica convidou
a sala a criar um projeto o lixo
procurasse uma situação-problema e
tentar solucionar ela através de
pesquisas e um Quem sabe um produto
final
então eu me dispus a participar e
através do pintor cego eu criei uma
situação-problema
Oi como posso explicar para crianças e
pessoas com deficiência visual O que são
as cores
e eu comecei mesmo instigação e uma
pesquisa e Através disso eu consegui
concluir que eu poderia explicar as
cores explorando outros sentidos como o
tato o olfato e audição
eu vou explicar um pouco para vocês
sobre cada um E depois eu vou mostrar ao
produto final bom primeiro aí Daniel o
tato Olha a gente trabalha com esses
gatinhos de baile que é espírita ajuda a
tátil para deficientes visuais
e
depois a gente trabalharia com o fato
Oriente trabalha com essências que
relacionam a cheirinho da natureza ou
chineses nosso dia a dia e por último
audição eu vou mostrar para vocês a
partir da audição daqui a pouco e assim
na audição às trabalharia com uma aula e
descrição onde escreveria Sensações e
sentimentos um exemplo que eu posso dar
para vocês é assim são corrente sente do
Sol quando o sol bate na nossa pele a
gente sente o calor o cliente então a
gente poderia relacionar a cores quentes
como o vermelho o laranja ou até mesmo
amarelo e a parte disso das minhas
pesquisas e da minha investigação eu
consegui criar uma paleta de cores para
deficiente slides
e ela se chama para Cor e a junção de
duas palavras é primeiro palheta e a
segunda de cores então paleta de cores e
aqui eu ativar e o sensor de voz
Oi aqui é onde a minha programação a voz
e a minha ao descrição ficam guardadas e
aqui são as variações as tintas estão
cheios depois de construir apacor eu
levei para seu PC
mas o que seria saber ser a CPC é um
centro de promoção à cidadania da pessoa
com deficiência visual E lá eu
apresentei uma menininha cega juntamente
com o professor de gale e a partir disso
depois de almoçar também no SPC ou o meu
o meu projeto teve o apoio deles e eu
pude concluir que o meu projeto não
seria somente para tentar entender o que
são as cores sem sentido da visão mas
que na verdade a gente poderia ter um
sentido muito mais aprofundado das
coisas e que a gente pode entender que
as coisas são lá sua vida inteira a
gente nunca percebeu Ele tá num cheiro
ele tá na sensação Ele tá em nossas
memórias ele serve para Memory e não é
qualquer Esporte aqueles potes por
exemplo Então as coisas são muito mais
do que a gente viver
e isso me que serviu de inspiração
quando a minha professora Érica sugeriu
a minha participar de uma feira chamada
desafio de inovação do Instituto 3M e
era 8ª mostra ela era uma ela é uma
feira Regional e Então é eu treinei para
participar da feira conseguimos
inscrição e apresentei em novembro quase
para dezembro Espera aí o resultado sai
em dezembro o resultado foi que eu
consegui o terceiro lugar na categoria
de Engenharia e assim me serviu para
inspiração participar de mais uma feira
porque assim quando eu ganhei a minha
família os meus amigos Nossa Ficaram tão
contentes que isso me Serviu de
inspiração para participar de outra ver
que foi a febrace que é uma feira
nacional e o a teve uma fase em
fevereiro de 2001 de divulgação onde eu
pude conhecer várias pessoas de todo o
Brasil e conhecer suas histórias
diferente ah e também precisa conhecer
pessoas com deficiência visual e depois
essa parte em março eu apresentei
esperei resultado sair novamente
e o resultado foi que eu consegui duas
premiações A primeira foi o prêmio
desenvolvedora social que alça me
reconheceu mais o vale-livro seu
certificado e eu adoro ler o Integral
que eu amo e o outro prêmio foi me
assistindo mas o que seria me desistir
meninas enfim é um termo onde tem a
ideia de
inspirar meninas entrarem na ciência mas
aí vem mais um questionamento vai ter
porque existiriam prêmio assim
bom desde o início dos tempos as
mulheres não tem muitas inspirações para
entrar em determinadas áreas como na
ciência um exemplo delas R Paty a que
foi a primeira mulher a ser considerada
a ciência durante os anos de 370 depois
de Cristo a410 depois de Cristo e assim
nessa ela ficou considerada a primeira
mulher mais a época Ainda já existiu
inúmeros homens dentro da ciência Então
porque aí baixa foi a primeira essa
considerada
Infelizmente essa desigualdade vem até
os dias atuais E então é por isso que a
gente precisa de um creme assim para
destacar minhas a ciência da mulheres
garotas e meninas como eu se inspirarem
e poderei
e poder inspirar nas outras se apoiar
bom então é além disso a gente a ciência
também pode crescer esse conjunto até
porque a ciência quanto mais pessoas
mais descobertas e inovações
então é agora no ano de 2001 Eu não
parei com uma projeto eu tô na segunda
fase dele com novos Melhoramentos
é o primeiro seria a minhas etiquetas a
gente que Deus que eu mostrei para vocês
são etiquetas de papel Então se
desgastam com o passar do tempo então
decidi que eu vou trocar por etiqueta de
alumínio
eu também vou mudar o estilo de
programação
primeiramente pela parte da voz porque
ano passado a minha dicção não era tão
boa como hoje em dia então eu vou mudar
isso eu vou mudar também a parte de
descrever as cores porque agora tem um
sentido muito mais aprofundado e por
último a parte total da programação esse
porque no último protótipo eu utilizei a
programação Lego e a gente sabe que a
programação Lego tem tem custos mais
elevados e um pouco mais caros então eu
decidi mudar
pela plataforma Arduino que era muito
mais barata e Inclusive eu que gosto de
todo mundo
e quem sabe né Futuramente eu posso
aplicar nas escolas tanto públicas
quanto privadas
assim todo mundo vai ter uma inscrição
melhor do que a arte e bem aqui para
finalizar para vocês eu queria passar um
exercício
é um dia na casa de vocês agora na
próxima palestra em qualquer lugar feche
os olhos
e tenta entender o que está acontecendo
essa arredar as pessoas falando os
passarinhos o barulho da moto o espaço
solidar
eu tô passando esse exercício porque
grande parte da ciência é feita de
empatia Então porque a gente não pode
começar agora muito obrigada